have children you have to encourage them
you have to encourage them to take risks
because they have to grow up and take
their place in the world you can't
protect them too much because if you do
you destroy them that's the motif of
Hansel and Gretel right two kids lost in
the woods they find the gingerbread
house that's a little bit too good to be
true right it's not only shelter when
you need it but it's candy what lives
inside the house that's too good to be
true the witch that devours you
right that's excess compassion so you
don't want your mother to do everything
for you that's for sure there's a rule
if you're dealing with the elderly and
like Extended Care Homes don't do
anything for your clients that they can
do themselves because you undermine
their autonomy and so there's a certain
amount of harshness that goes along with
that just as there is if you're a good
mother because you have to separate
yourself from your child and allow them
to make hurtful mistakes right I mean
it's always very difficult if you're a
compassionate person to stand back far
enough to let your children take
necessary risks